stop eating these foods as they can not
only make you sick but if not prepared
properly poison you to death stay tuned
to the end of this video to also see
what food you're not eating that you
definitely should be
apple seeds no it's not cause an apple a
day keeps a doctor away it's because
apple seeds contain amygdalin a compound
that's broken down by your gut into
cyanide that's why they actually taste
bitter cyanide is actually a poison that
hurts your blood's ability to carry
oxygen leading to hypoxemia and
eventually death good news though your
putty can actually break down small
amounts of cyanide and you'd have to eat
hundreds or even thousands of seeds to
be at risk for poisoning fugu or puffer
fish as seen in movies puffer fish in
the dish prepared for me can be
extremely poisonous the ovaries
intestines and liver fugu contain
tetrodotoxin which is a neurotoxin
that's up to 1200 times more deadly than
cyanide fugu chefs must undergo years of
training to obtain a proper preparing
license and despite these precautions
numerous people still die every year
from their fugu being improperly
prepared this puffer poisoning usually
results from consumption of incorrectly
prepared puffer soup called fugu chiri
or occasionally from raw puffer meat
known as sashimi fugu if it's not
correctly prepared fugu can paralyze
your nervous system and shut down your
respiratory muscles meaning this fish
can cause you to drown when you're not
even in the water rhubarb rhubarb is a
plant whose stock is often used in pies
muffins cakes and although rhubarb is
botanically a vegetable it's classified
as a fruit here in the united states
their leaves contain high levels of
oxalic acid which is a corrosive and
acidic substance that can lead to kidney
failure and even death and i stressed
high levels because other healthy
vegetables like broccoli and spinach
also have oxalic acid and they're just
fine for us so don't use this as an
excuse to skip out on your veggies it's
truly the dose that makes the poison
actually a wild story is that during
world war one when vegetable stock was
real low the leaves were mistakenly
recommended as a food source in britain
leading to poisonings and even deaths
whoa elderberries okay i admit
elderberries are delicious and actually
not poisonous if cooked and ripe but the
rest of the tree they grow on including
its twigs leaves roots and seeds contain
bitter alkaloids that produce
hydrocyanic acid if elderberries aren't
fully riped or strained properly when
they're processed they can cause nausea
vomiting and severe severe diarrhea
according to the cdc there was actually
an instance when a people attending a
religious ceremony in monterey county
were airlifted to the hospital after
drinking a special juice that had been
made with among other things elderberry
leaves and branches they all survived
but not before violently violently
vomiting just 15 minutes after drinking
the juice make sure you know who's
making your drinks and with what red
kidney beans actually a lot of legumes
can cause an upset stomach when
undercooked but red kidney beans
certainly take the cake and that's
because red kidney beans contain a
natural protein called lectin within
just a few hours of consuming pha
symptoms of nausea vomiting diarrhea and
abdominal pain may appear this pha is
the bean's natural defense system like
our immune system but rest assured as
pha is destroyed by proper preparation
and legumes are most definitely a
healthy source of protein if properly
prepared but it's not just a matter of
cooking them in fact according to the
fda cooking dried red kidney beans for
less than 10 minutes at any temperature
less than boiling can actually increase
the toxicity fivefold making them far
more toxic than if you just ate them raw
castor oil seeds or beans castor oil is
notoriously known for being used as a
laxative to help you poop specifically
it's a stimulant laxative meaning that
increases the movement of the muscles in
the intestines helping out with
constipation however if you watch the
show breaking bad or my reaction to the
show you know that the deadly poison
ricin shown on the show is made by
crushing caster seeds it is reassuring
to know that to make castor oil from the
seeds we use heat during the oil
extraction process to actually destroy
the toxin lychee lychee sangria lychee
martini lychee ice cream yum lychees are
delicious and are hydrating fruit that
have many health benefits if eaten
correctly and in moderation but if
you're eating raw green unripe and
lychees on an empty stomach that can
prove to be extremely dangerous to your
health for 20 years doctors observed an
alarming trend in the northern region of
india where every spring hundreds of
children would randomly have seizures
slip into comas dying in 40 of the cases
fail tests after failed tests later
scientists finally determined that the
under underfed children were eating
unripe and lychees that fell to the
ground and they contain high levels of a
naturally occurring amino acid
derivative called hypoglycin this caused
the children to wake screaming in the
night before suffering convulsions and
losing consciousness as they suffered
acute swelling of their brains luckily
since this discovery incidents from
unripened lychees in india have fallen
to under 50 a year nutmeg get this the
delicious little bit of nutmeg that you
add to your pasta eggnog and sauces may
be yummy but over ingesting the spice
can actually be fatal nutmeg contains a
compound called miracin a psychoactive
substance that in larger doses can
actually poison your system and cause
organ failure miracin is actually
cytotoxic meaning that it instructs your
own cells to destroy themselves in fact
just eating two three teaspoons of
nutmeg can result in seizures irregular
heartbeat nausea dizziness dry mouth
pain and hallucinations similar to the
ones people get when taking peyote i
still remember my med school toxicology
professor sharing that nutmeg is
metabolized into mmda in the body to
produce hallucinogenic effects and as a
result has romantically and historically
been linked as a potential way to get
high trust me though this is a horrible
horrible idea as the vomiting and
toxicity make it a terrible recreational
drug there are also no known current
antidotes for merest dyson poisoning and
treatment focuses on symptom management
and airway protection only potatoes
potatoes are not poisonous in the way
that we usually consume them so relaxed
but if you consume a green potato or
even one with a greenish tint it likely
means that a glycoalkaloid poison named
solanine is also present this is an
actual nerve toxin that can result in
vomiting diarrhea paralysis and even
death if ingested in very high mouths
also you know those little sprouts and
stems that we commonly refer to as eyes
that grow on potatoes as they age they
contain the same glycoalkaloid so don't
eat the stems don't eat green potatoes
and remember just because potatoes are
technically a vegetable doesn't mean
they can replace your broccoli at dinner
i'm watching you cashews did you know
that unlike money cashews do grow on
trees and you probably have seen me eat
raw cashews on this channel as a snack
but truth be told they're not actually
raw and thank god for that as cashews
have to be heat treated to remove
urushiol which is a poisonous chemical
it's actually the same chemical that
causes a poison ivy rash consuming truly
raw cashews straight from the tree can
cause skin rashes and extreme sometimes
fatal allergic reactions now for the one
that you're supposed to eat kiwi skin
some of you may not like its texture but
health benefit-wise it's really solid
the skin contains nutrients like fiber
folate vitamin c and e adding the skin
of the kiwi boosts the fruits fiber
content by 50
and as someone who's struggling to get
my fiber the furry skin texture may be
worth the trade-off however as a little
word of warning if you have a tendency
to develop kidney stones you may want to
look elsewhere for your antioxidant kit
which is healthier real meat or fake
meat click here to find out and as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]